like the internet didn't
get created because people sat down and
tried to figure out
how do i uh you know uh send tick-tock
videos of myself dancing to people
they you know it was there's an
application
i mean actually i don't even know what
do you think the application for the
internet was when it was
it must have been very low level basic
network communication within darpa
like military based like how do i send
like a networking how do i send
information securely
between two places maybe it was an
encryption
i'm totally speaking totally outside of
my knowledge but like
it was probably intended for a very
narrow small group of people
well so i mean it was there was like
this small community of people who were
really interested in time sharing
computing and like interactive computing
in contrast with uh batch processing
and then the idea that as you set up
like a time sharing center
uh basically meaning you have multiple
people like logged in and using that
like central computer
um why not make it accessible to others
yeah and this was kind of what i
always thought like oh is this like
fringe group that was interested in this
new kind of computing and they all like
got themselves together
but the thing is like darpa wouldn't act
you wouldn't have the us government
funding that just for the funds of it
right but in some sense that's what arpa
was all about was
uh like just really advanced research
for the sake of having advanced research
and it doesn't have to
pay out with utility soon but uh the
core parts of its development were
happening
like in the middle of the vietnam war
when there was budgetary constraints
all over the place uh i only learned
this recently actually like
if you look at the documents basically
justifying the
um budget for the arpanet as they were
developing it
and not just keeping it where it was but
actively growing it while all sorts of
other departments were having their
funding cut
because of the war a big part of it was
national defense in terms of having like
a more robust communication system
like the idea of packet switching versus
circuit switching you could kind of make
this case that
in some calamitous circumstance where
you know a central location gets nuked
uh this is a this is a much more
resilient way to still have your
communication lines that
like traditional um telephone lines
weren't as resilient to
which i just found very interesting that
that um
even something that we see as so
happy-go-lucky is just a bunch of
computer nerds trying to get like
interactive computing out there
the actual like thing that made it uh
funded and thing that made it advance
uh when it did was because of this
direct national security
question and concern i don't know if
you've read it i haven't read it i've
been meaning to read it but neil
degrasse tyson
actually came out with a book that talks
about like
science and the context of the military
like basically saying
all the great science we've done in the
in the 20th century was
like because of the military i mean he
paints a positive
it's not like a critical it's not you
know a lot of people say like military
industrial complex and so on
another way to see the military and
national security is like
a source of like you said deadlines and
like hard things you can't move
like almost you know almost like scaring
ourselves into being productive
it is that i mean manhattan project is a
perfect example probably the
quintessential example
that one uh is a little bit more macabre
than others because of like what they
were building
but in terms of how many focused smart
hours of human intelligence get pointed
towards
a topic per day you're just maxing it
out with that sense of worry in that
context everyone there was saying like
we've got to get the bomb before hitler
does
and that like that just lights a fire
under you that
i again like the circumstances macabre
but i think that's actually pretty
healthy
especially for researchers that are
otherwise going to be really theoretical
to take these like theorizers and say
make this real physical thing happen
meaning a lot of it is going to be
unsexy a lot of it's going to be like
young firemen sitting there kind of
inventing
a notion of computation in order to like
compute what they needed to compute
more quickly with like the rudimentary
automated tools that they had available
um i think you see this with bell labs
also where
you've got otherwise very theorizing
minds in very pragmatic contexts
that i think is like really helpful for
the theory as well as for the
applications
so i think that stuff can be positive
for
progress
you